cris chantage gifle la fondation pour
l'enfance
alerte sur les violences éducatives
ordinaires avec une nouvelle campagne de
sensibilisation ces brimades perdure
dans les familles françaises pourtant
elles sont interdites par la loi depuis
juillet 2019
il faut dire que le chemin pour arriver
à cette législation a été lent parmi
ceux ci on donne quoi fait ça il fait sa
une grosse fessée
et qu'est ce que tu fais toi maman dans
les années 70 l'avc c'était une norme
éducative
elle était même recommandé écouter 7 6 4
sur le plateau de l'émission aujourd'hui
madame et ce tout à fait certain qu'un
enfant qui est dans une crise
d'agitation notre monde peut très bien
être
tranquillisés physiquement et moralement
par une bonne tape sur les fesses qui
met fin à ces gesticulations une bonne
tape de temps en temps pour remettre les
idées en place
sur le plateau les mères de famille
valider la théorie tout sauf une je
pense qu'il ya d'autres punitions la
fessée je crois que c'est surtout au
soulagement des parents plutôt un
discours rare à l'époque en 1979 les
suédois sont les premiers à bannir les
punitions sur les ans la nouvelle
faisait l'ouverture du jt de léon
zitrone le parlement suédois vient
d'être saisie de la question et je viens
de voter
presqu'à l'unanimité une loi interdisant
désormais tout châtiment corporel
entraînant une souffrance morale ou
physique
même légère j'ai un enfant d'autres pays
suivront l'exemple mais en france la
fessée à la vie dure témoignages de
parents 1980
mchugh quelques-unes
les parents peuvent s'appeler faire que
du bien et 21 ans plus tard en 2002 a
dit une fois deux fois trois fois jérémy
ne fait pas jérémy le voilà et quand
jérémy va jusqu'au bout et il fait je ne
dis plus une quatrième fois je me fais
c'est alors en 2015 c'est au tour de la
france de se faire taper sur les doigts
le conseil de l'europe condamne le pays
pour n'avoir toujours pas interdit les
châtiments comme la fessée sur les
enfants
la pédiatre engagé edwige antier se
réjouissait de cette initiative
c'est une grande victoire et je salue le
courage du conseil de l'europe
il faut que ce soit inscrit dans le code
civil
ça veut dire les châtiments corporels ce
n'est pas un geste éducatif il n'existe
pas pour l'éducation des enfants
aujourd'hui en france la fessée et
toutes les punitions éducatives sont
interdites par la loi
mais d'après une récente étude 36 % des
parents ignorent ce qu'est une violence
éducative ordinaire et 33 % ne savent
toujours pas quelle sont interdites en
france
[Musique]